up seven o'donovich
over dingles
ty lue wants them to foul
and we have what looks like an ejection
scott foster pointed it i think reggie
jackson
i don't know or paul george donovan was
on the ground they were way away from
the
play and he hit the deck
and is in some serious pain trying to
figure out what happened here
mitchell favoring that right leg oh
is it the ankle
[Applause]
remember he missed the last 16 games of
the regular season
with an injury he was favoring that
right leg on the way down
[Applause]
so it's just a foul call on paul george
it was just scott foster being really
demonstrative with the call
okay i saw where you were going with it
because he was so demonstrative
donovan mitchell with 36 tonight
very efficient a little below 50 from
the field 15 to 29
6 for 12 from deep much better job in
the second half he had 30 at the half or
excuse me 27 at the first half
but mark the pickup point was different
right they're double teams
became i thought better closing the gaps
he made the requisite adjustments too
right
that's what i'm saying clippers may have
found something defensively with him
twin snyder says that donovan